che bel polline anche per polline che
sono allergico sta merda e mi giravo
[ __ ] sono mangio muoio belle tutti
ragazzi e benvenuti a questo momento
sono felice ed oggi siamo oggi si corre
domenica non siamo solo è più visto
perché siamo arrivati alla centesima
puntata quindi prendo un attimo di pausa
da è primis ma tranquilli che lo faccio
state calmi
sei ragazzi sun life the game che
sarebbe il gioco della vita cioè nel
senso la traduzione italiana del titolo
e il gioco della vita
non so perché mi chiave è live di
gameplay non so that bon nasci devono
devo nascerà proprio devo a addio era
sfruttato una testa a caso è ci provo
bush ma è quindi devono essere proprio a
sei rimasto bloccato per tre giorni
tentando di uscire la tua madre quando
finalmente ce l'hai fatta tua madre era
così stanca che ti ha messo in adozione
ok e non ha mai provato a ricontattati
ancora solo perché non sono riuscito a
uscire brutta [ __ ] che sboccia faccia a
faccia dai dai dai dai dai
fuck yeah ce l'ha fatta parlata può
parlare a ok lo cliccare su sti cosi si
ma in realtà io sento solo una
canzoncina di sottofondo stupidamente a
non sto parlando questo è parlare zio
complimenti stai dicendo parole
sensatissimi studia ecco questo non lo
so fare ragazzi a 12 più cioè fermi a 17
il [ __ ] f meno ai odiato la
matematica così tanto che hai lasciato
la scuola otto anni la storia della mia
vita quando è richiesta di lavorare per
capovolgere gli hamburger la tua
richiesta è stata respinta ragione sopra
qualificato eh vabbè e mi resta che
farlo youtuber try again proviamoci
ancora resta diceva posso fargli 12 17
3h cazzo è il 20 si sa più ap va bene va
bene pubertà no vabbè ma che schifo ma
seriamente ma che merda apre
l'apparecchio che schifo che se
spiaccicata la roba verde sullo schermo
dopo l'incidente con le pustole sei
diventato conosciuto con il nome di tipo
con la faccia da capezzolo
perché cioè capezzoli sembrano le
pustole giusto un anno dopo hai
accettato risparmiando un intervento
chirurgico ho fatto e dato cugino alan
perché mio cugino alan fa gli interventi
chirurgici ok e sei morto sotto i ferri
ed è meta la grande ala beh questo avere
un cugino e ha studiato su surgeons il
muletto try again da ci riprovo povertà
a me è difficile clicca su sti cosi c'è
seriamente da the poor sole ciò sul naso
che non ho il naso procione busto è
fantastico ok a perfetto resti che sei
figo è spuntata la bocca dieci anni
finder acque dentro alla ragazza che era
questa mi piace bella questa è no questa
sembra mia nonna
questa sembra katy perry va bene certo è
chi non vorrebbe bella il match sport
siano fatto trovata la ragazza è stato
semplice se fosse così facile trovare la
ragazza nella vita reale barca [ __ ]
purtroppo io nella vita reale urlo come
una [ __ ] nei horror il che non aiuta
ve lo assicuro sports cosa vuol dire che
questo è uno sport cioè lanciare le
palline da ping pong nella birra è uno
sport
lanciamo fa chi è a questa è proprio la
pubertà c'è mi sto briag andò fantastico
chi non si è ubriacato quando ho trovato
la ragazza per la prima volta interna
che è successo a o passa o vinto
perfetto sobria gatto non mi ricordo
niente make coffee
[Musica]
[Applauso]
grandissimo non solo ai avvelenato il
tuo boss che non era neanche mio caffè
sei stato licenziato dal lavoro dei tuoi
sogni sei stato condannato per tentato
omicidio e hai speso i successivi 20
anni della tua vita in una prigione con
un compagno di cella chiamato papà orso
posso farvi una domanda ragazzi ma che
cazzo hanno fumato quelli che hanno
fatto sto gioco mamma serio cioè dei
ragazzi devo fare io non riesco a farlo
nella vita di tutti i giorni caffè ve lo
dico è caffelatte e chiodi a caso io
imbecille c'era scritto une imbecille
get out
l'udc suoi nel caffè al lido zucca scusa
sono scemo eccellente hai tenuto il tuo
lavoro e perché mio lavoro è quello di
fare il caffè e giustamente lavoro dei
miei sogni
ma cos'è ma che i capelli già il signor
un filo le le cose hanno raffigurato da
carcerato sui tattico guarda le
scarpette che io ho fatto
beh perché sei triste il tuo senso di
fashion glamour mandato la tua ragazza
fuori completamente fuori di testa è
impazzita ed è corsa via conto cugino
alan ancora [ __ ] a la regala mi
deve rovinare la vita
che palle non sapevo neanche di avere un
cugino di nome a la maledizione ai
fantasia che era pure in mutande prima
fantastico ma chi ea quale alla mia
sposa può far nascere mio figlio ammazzo
e sicura trombano che a metà basta si
midlife oddio questa la crisi di mezza
età compro una nuova macchina nuovi deva
ma fammi leggere oddio cosa ho comprato
cos'è ho comprato una fava non lo so vi
va bene non potevo comprare altrimenti
una nuova macchina messa nel carrello i
pesi per gli era giusti ieri anche nel
carrello i tre vertici come è giusto in
questo è sbagliato aravecchia cielo
travel ticket che con alla fine poi
waits e sarebbe ripesi non è giusto
invece è anche primario sei scemo gran
children o mio dio soviet ato vecchio
cosa fa
non è vero non è l'unico kick ass ha
fatto questo giorno vi prego di teme lo
stiamo facendo le visite ai miei nipoti
questi vanno a toccare la corrente
elettrica con le mani si può essere così
deficienti idol tenerli lontani dalla
presa elettrica del detersivo e dal
fuoco gioco dell'anno
ce l'ho fatta perfetto sei out in a dove
organizzare le pastiglie sono vecchio
però ce la faccio oddio non è
esattamente così
aspetta aspetta aspetta aspetta spettano
a addio ragazze 1 impedito come se fossi
vecchio sul serio ve lo dico ma no dai
messa dori cazzola immessa quella vai
vai vai vai crema anche un dovere ma
anche due bikers manca una tra perfetto
il viagra al suo posto e anche stanotte
ci divertiamo come se avessimo vent'anni
se muori
avevo così dove io devo aiutarmi a
morire ma viene a bara ma poverino ma
david emmi che scenda la lacrimuccia ci
ho messo una vita ma fa qualcosa ma
perché non posso far niente da è
tristissimo cioè aiutato il vecchietto a
tenere lontano i bambini dalle dal fuoco
ne ho preso il via libera sono morto
perché hai per eccesso di viagra va bene
è stato detto che tutta la tua vita ti
passa davanti agli occhi prima che tu
muoia
se questo è vero si chiama vita terry
pratchett di sicuro questa frase nome la
scritta mio cugino alan non avevo dubbi
riguardo da che ora ragazzi questa life
2 game gioco che merita di essere
vissuto dal profondo per l'amor di dio è
meraviglioso l'unica roba che non ho
capito è perchè tipo la mia vita è molto
più triste di questo videogame cioè nel
senso è tutto molto più facile anche
imparare a parlare è stato difficile
santo iddio qua è una cagata mi è
piaciuto veramente tanto se non fosse
per il fatto che che con la matematica
io faccio schifo sono riuscito quadri
sono ricordato cioè fortuna l'alzheimer
ancora ancora non arrivato però il
lavoro quello da di flippare gli
hamburger non era
se non fosse per il fatto che trovare
una ragazza non è così semplice per il
resto veramente rispecchia la realtà di
tutti i giorni quindi fantastico aiutato
me lo sto rifacendo tutto perché una
dovrebbe mettere una foto così su un
sito di incontri spiegano ragazzi sta
parte qui l'ho adorato avanti guardati
bambini come sono belli è stato un gioco
stupendo ragazzi analizzandolo sotto
tutti i punti di vista posso
professionalmente descrivere questo come
uno dei titoli videoludici migliori del
2016 e soprattutto voce da uomo per un
bambino che strilla 10 su 10
niente ragazzi storia che vide vi sia
piaciuto cosa è piaciuto lasciato al
momento è un mi piace ai capitani
facebook che ho invitato tanti iniziano
gli eserciti stranieri ci vediamo il
prossimo video mi raccomando nella fase
della pubertà centrata dal bicchiere con
le palline da ping pong che è importante
nella vita fa vjc insegnamenti di vita
del cazzo da lì